you guys look at my pimple it's so gross
it's like a planet on my face it's
forming yeah that's kind of nasty
seriously yeah okay wait what are they
saying
I'm gonna call you Donald
have you tried washing your face though
of course I washed my face yeah you
always wash my face mmm
you should try Proactiv I was reading
was stuff online and I mean basically
you should go vegan are you [ __ ]
kidding me
I just need something to work every
everyday though not just like every week
or something this guy yeah hey you know
makeups bad for your skin you shouldn't
put a lot of it on well my skin is
pretty bad for my skin so I don't know
why I shouldn't hide in my skin hmm
maybe I should use skin clearing apps oh
that does not look like me wish I had
her skin but she only has one kind of
soap maybe all my Instagram's can just
be my drawings he always throws like the
crease oh my god Emma did you draw that
yeah oh my god you see this looks so
good that is Bob like it's not that bad
your stand-up person you've got friends
you don't look like Shrek
could be worse oh they're not going to
be there forever I'm fine you got it if
you don't watch it every now you're
gonna get acne that's why I don't have
it happy because I wash my face yes
Henry night and day I wash my face